[موسيقى]
صغيره وانا كنت
الكيوليشن دايما ببص على الحاجات بشكل
مختلف ودائما طول الوقت عندي اسئله ماما
انا اسفه بجد انا عارفه انا سالت كتير
اسئله كنت بسالها طول الوقت ليه
ازاي عشان ايه ايش معنى
واكتر اجابه محبطه في الدنيا بالنسبه لي
كانت كلمه كده ايوه ليه كده ايوه يا جماعه
ليه عشان ايه هو كده عشان كده ما تناقشيش
ما تجديش ما تساليش طالما الكبار قالوا لك
ده صح كده يبقى ده هو الصح
وقتها قناعه انه كل الناس الكبار اللي
حواليا بابا ماما قرايبي المدرسين
الدكاتره في الكليه لما هيقولوا لي حاجه
على انها صح انا خلاص هاخدها مسلم بها
وهتعمل معها
وكبرت وعندي شويه قناعات حلوه كده عن نفسي
وعن الحياه وعن النجاح وعن الدنيا وعن
احنا المفروض نعيش ازاي قناه زي مثلا ان
ما فيش حاجه اسمها حد ياخد وقته ايه ياخد
وقته دي كل ما عملنا الحاجه اسرع كل ما ده
كان صح اكتر مين اسرع حد هيسلم الهوم ورك
مين اسرع حد هيعمل رسمه مين اسرع حد هيخلص
طبقه كل ما كانت كل حاجه بتتعمل اسرع كل
ما ده احسن وكل ما حد اخد وقته يبقى الحد
ده مش شاطر
قنوات زي انه مثلا الشخص اللي بيبتدي حاجه
ويمشي فيها شويه وما يكملش يبتدي حاجه
ثانيه ده شخص فاشل
قناعات زي مثلا انه الهوايات طالما ما
بتترجمش ولا المصدر دخل ولا لمصدر تباهي
اجتماعي باي شكل من الاشكال تبقى تضييع
فلوس وتضييع وقت
وانه كمان النجاح يعني معنى الحياه
الناجحه هو ان احنا نجيب درجات كويسه في
المدرسه نجيب تقدير كويس في الكليه نشتغل
في وظيفه مناسبه نتجوز جوازه كويسه نخلف
ولاد نربيهم تربيه كويسه برافو احنا كده
تمام
كم حد هنا اتقال له انه النجاح بعدد
الشهادات نرفع ايدينا كده الله نفس لوحدي
طب الحمد لله كويس جدا
فلقيت نفسي حياتي كل الحاجات دي ولقيت
نفسي فجاه كده واقفه في نص التلاتينات
واللي هو لماذا نحن هنا ايوه خير انا
ناجحه اهو يا جماعه ولا ايه يعني انا عملت
كل حاجات خالص خدت السكور خلاص كله فايه
بقى ايه اللي بيحصل
فلقيت نفسي واقفه انا مش عارفه وانا بحقق
النجاحات دي هل انا كنت فرحانه عشان انا
فعلا فرحانه
ولا انا كنت فرحانه عشان المفروض ابقى
فرحانه عشان عملت الحاجات اللي هيدي صح هو
ده النجاح ولا انا مش فرحانه اصلا بس
بحاول اعمل فرحانه عشان المفروض ان انا
ابقى فرحانه بالحاجات اللي انا حققتها
وحقيقي ما كنتش عارفه انا بعمل ايه فلو حد
فهمكم انكم في الثلاثينات في نص
الثلاثينات بتعملوا ايه في الدنيا هنا كدب
عليكم جدا يعني مش مضبوط
ومش بس الصدمه انه كانت حياه اغلبهم لا
تمت بصله للتصور عن النجاح اللي انا كنت
ماشيه عليهم متعوده عليه لا ده كمان الناس
اللي بتحكي قصص الناس الناجحه دي اصلا كان
كل تركيزهم على هما اتعلموا ايه بس وكان
فايقتهم نقطه مهمه جدا جدا
الناس دي عشان يوصلوا للنجاحات دي كانوا
محتاجين يغيروا نظرتهم عن نفسهم كانوا
محتاجين يلغوا فكره عن نفسهم اتزرعت جوه
دماغهم قبل كده الناس الناجحه دي
ووقتها انا قررت ان انا اخد باص جديد في
نص الثلاثينات انا اسمي كنز سليمان
اني الغي فكره انا مكوناها عن نفسي
اتزرعت فيا بسبب نظره حد تاني وانا بدل مع
كواستشن النظره دي خدتها مسلم ومشيت بها
زي ايه زي مثلا مدرسه التدبير المنزلي كان
في حاجه اسمها تبديل منزلي على ايامي على
فكره وانا في اعدادي كانوا بيعلمونا كده
اشغال يدويه وحاجات قالت لي ان انا عمري
ما هعرف امسك ابره او اعمل اي شغل يدوي
فيه ابره عشان في الفصل انا كنت الوحيده
في حصتها اللي ما عرفتش حاجه عملت حاجه
اسمها غرزه السلسله بالكروشيه المفروض
انها سهله اي حد يقدر يعملها فانت عمرك ما
هتعرفي تمسكي ابره خالص
زي مثلا صحابي ايام ثانوي ايام الجامعه
لما كانوا بيقولوا لي انت ولا بتعرفي
تصوري ولا بتعرفي تتصوري وفي كل رحله كان
لازم كله يشيل الكاميرا من ايد كنزه يا
جماعه ما حدش كنزه تصور
زي مثلا برغم اني كنت بكسب مسابقات كثيره
جدا في المدرسه في اعدادي وفي ثانوي في
الكتابه وكنت حابه ان انا ابقى كاتبها
ويبقى عندي كتابي الخاص بعثت المجله عينه
من مقال علشان اكتب عندهم وردوا علي
بالايميل بلينك الكتاب عن تعليم اسس
الكتابه ومش بس قالوا لي ان اسلوب كتابتي
ركيك قالوا ان هو لا يرقى لمستوى المجله
بتاعتها
كل دي حاجات انا كنت مصدقاها عن نفسي فكنت
ناجحه قدام الناس كلها ناجحه بس من جوايا
شايفه ان انا ما ينفعش اخد وقتي ان
الهوايات تضييع وقت انه لو انا بدات حاجه
وما كملتش فيها لا لازم اكمل فيها حتى لو
مبقتش بحبها حتى لو بتاذيني طالما بدات
لازم اكمل ولازم اكلم وخلاص عشان كده
فقررت ان انا محتاجه ان انا اكواسشن
الكلام ده ابص على كل حاجه بمنظور مختلف
اعمل للحاجات اللي انا صدقتها عن نفسي دي
ووقتها ابتدت رحلتي مع الاندرنينج قالت
فوق ممكن تتخيله بمجرد ما تلونوا نفسكوا
غيرتوا فكره عن نفسكم والموضوع اشتغل خلاص
بقى احنا ماشيين كاننا بنلعب بالظبط
وعاملين سكور ورا الثاني ورا الثالث وفي
منتهى السعاده اللي حصل انه عندي على
السوشيال ميديا كانوا في ناس كثيره جدا من
صحابي بيعملوا حاجه اسمها او تحدي 100 يوم
سعاده
لو سمعته عنه بشكل او باخر وكان عاجبني
جدا توثيقهم للحظاتهم السعيده والطريقه
اللي هم ماشيين بها وكنت عايزه ادخل مع
نفسي في تحدي اني ابص على كل حاجه بوجهه
نظري انا واني اكشن كل حاجه انا عارفاها
عن نفسي لغايه دلوقتي
بس عشان اعمل ما ينفعش امشي التحدي زي
الفكره المتعارف عليها بتاعه التحديات انه
لو عامل التحدي ميت يوم يبقى لازم كل يوم
ورا بعض بالترتيب لمده 100 يوم والا لو
وقفتي في النص تبقي فاشله ما بتضيعي وقت
وهتضري تعيدي من الاول
فقلت خلاص انا هبتدي ان انا اول حاجه انا
هدي نفسي هتحدى نفسي لمده 100 يوم ان انا
اغير نظرتي لنفسي ونظرتي على كل حاجه
حواليا وال 100 يوم دول هيبقوا متقطعين
وهيبقوا على مدار سنه والله بقى جه كم يوم
ورا بعض ماشي دي اسبوع ورا بعض ماشي دي
اسبوع وقفت خالص ماشي هسمح لنفسي اني ادي
لنفسي وقت اوكي ماشي يا كنز انا مستعده
نعمل ايه كمان نوثق التحدي ده ازاي تصوير
ما تيجي نجرب نصور بالموبايل بدل ما
شايفين
اي حد صورنا
اوكي يبقى انا هعمل فولدر على بروفايل على
فيسبوك بابلك اوثق فيه كل سنه 100 صوره في
السنه في 100 يوم في السنه بغير فيهم
طريقه تفكيري عن كل حاجه
فكره ورا فكره
حرفيا
لايف ما بقتش مصدقه ان دي انا في كم سنه
اللي عدوا دول
غيرت مفاهيم كثيره جدا عن نفسي زي مثلا
مدرستي اللي قالت لي انها ان انا عمري ما
هامسك ابره دي اتعلمت حاجه اسمها فن
البنشنيدل او ابره النفاش لو تعرفوه وعملت
به حاجات بايدي واتعلمت الفساتين لما قررت
ان انا الغي الفكره دي عن نفسي
كنت عايزه اكتب كتاب وما عرفتش
سجلت كتابي بصوتي وبقى عندي
وبعد كده شاركت في تاليف كتابين تانيين
كمان
فهنا
وقفت وسالت نفسي انا دلوقتي عايزه اعمل
نفسي سيستم امشي عليه كل مره يكون عندي
ليفل جديد عايزه ادخله في حياتي او تحدي
جديد انا واقفه عنده ومش قادره اخطي
الخطوه اللي بعدها انا محتاجه اعمل ايه
اربع خطوات سحريه
اسمح لنفسي ان انا اوقف كل حاجه بعملها
دلوقتي واخد خطوه لورا وابص على الموضوع
من بره
ايه اللي انا شايفاه عن نفسي وعن الهدف ده
او عن الخطوه دي محتاجه اغيره
un اغير فكرتي عن نفسي شايفه نفسي ما
بعرفش اعمل كذا اعيد اختبار الفكره دي انا
عرفت دي منين عرفتها من مين اللي قال لي
ان انا ما بعرفش اعمل كذا وانا احاول
دلوقتي ممكن اعرف ممكن كنت فاكره اني ما
بعرفش اعرف اعمل ده قبل كده بقيت اعرف
وبعدين بعد ما اعمل
ابتدي من الاول حقي اني ابتدي من الاول
مره واثنين وثلاثه وميه
ابتدي من الاول بس بعقليتي الجديده وفكرتي
الجديده وبعدين جوه انطلق ما بقاش خايفه
من حاجه ولا خايفه من حد لاني بجرب واثق
كل خطوه انا بخطيها
لو انتم فاكرين انه
ودلوقتي كلنا محتاجين نسال نفسنا سؤال
هو المدرس اللي قال ان احنا مش هنفلح في
حاجه ده كان معاه جائزه نوبل في كل حاجه
وعارف كل حاجه
هي طنط اللي قالت لك دخلتك شكلها وحش ولا
اللون ده مش لايق عليكي ولا السكرتي شكلها
مطولك او مقصرك كانت فاشن وعارفه كل حاجه
في كل حاجه
هو اليوفي
محتاجين نعرف ونعتبر النهارده كده
[موسيقى]